you're not going to the gym anymore but
you're still
doing some sort of resistance training
uh you can maintain basically all of
your gains for
a very very long period of time so there
have been quite a few studies on this
one of them will be linked in the show
notes it's by bickle and colleagues from
2011 exercise dosing to retain
resistance training adaptations in young
and older adults and so in this training
basically they had younger adults so
people from 20 to 35 years old and older
adults people from 60 to 75 years old
train for 16 weeks so train for four
months and then have a period of reduced
training volume for eight months and so
during that eight eight month period
they reduced their training volume by
either two thirds or eight ninths
and what they found is and and so you
know we're talking about like a seventy
percent reduction in volume or like a
ninety percent reduction in volume and
they found that for the older the older
adults they could reduce their training
volume by two-thirds and still maintain
muscle and strength for eight months so
that's that's a a large reduction but
still doing about a third of what you
were previously
and and maintaining virtually everything
for the younger adults
that that eight ninth reduction doing
just one ninth of the training volume
they were previously was sufficient to
maintain or even slightly increase
strength and muscularity over eight
months so
you know if you're taking
if you're taking a month out of the gym
like you're you're going on the vacation
of your dreams or just you're burned out
and maybe your gym doesn't have air
conditioning and you live in the south
and you're like you know what [ __ ] that
i'm not going to be in that warehouse
gym in the month of july in the state of
alabama that's [ __ ] i'm not doing it
uh that's totally fine you can like
just doing a little resistance training
we're talking like
maybe three or four sets of like
push-ups pull-ups uh uh body weight
split squats per week
you will probably lose a little muscle
lose a little strength but you're gonna
maintain virtually all of your gains for
a long long period of time just by doing
a little bit of something so uh
yeah that's that's what i have to say on
the topic in general up to a month off
probably fine uh if you do just a little
bit of training you can stretch that out
to eight months or you might even still
be able to make a little bit of progress
over a month or two of severely
diminished training volume um but then
you know on the other extreme end
complete immobilization very very bad
news you lose a lot of muscle a lot of
strength very quickly the other big
thing to consider is age so you can get
away with time out of the gym a little
bit easier if you're younger
rather than older
yeah i i just have one thing to add here
a very common thing that you'll see is
someone will be like hey i'm gonna be
out of the gym for like six weeks
because of some
circumstance
uh
but i'm gonna increase my protein intake
and so i'm gonna be fine i'm gonna
retain all my muscle because of that so
i cool i think it's important to
recognize like every step that you
mentioned every proactive step
involved
movement activity training yes uh if you
remove that activity that training
stimulus and think that you know protein
is going to get you out of a bind here
the the evidence is terrible for that it
just doesn't seem to work uh so like
there have been studies where they do
some pretty um
they they try to induce atrophy in a
number of different ways often with
immobilization
increasing dietary protein just doesn't
seem to do anything at all
there are a couple studies indicating
that maybe possibly
leucine might do a little bit of
something kind of
but generally speaking it's just i i
wouldn't even bother with a protein or a
leucine intervention and a lot of times
um oddly enough like it kind of
backfires a little bit because people
will be so adamant about getting an
extra protein during this period of low
activity they actually probably eat more
calories than they need and so then when
they come back they've still if it's a
really extended period of time and
they've really reduced their activity
level they come back and they have every
bit of
loss of strength and muscularity that
they would have without the protein
intervention i mean it did not save them
any preservation of strength or muscle
but they also gained a little bit more
fat than they would have liked to so if
anything it kind of in terms of their
fitness goals sometimes it kind of digs
that whole paradoxically a little bit
deeper because it's like well i still
got to regain all that strength and
muscle and there's a little more fat to
lose that i didn't really plan for yeah
so nutrition stuff i honestly wouldn't
even bother aside from just good healthy
nutrition practices for sure so really
the two big takeaways is
if if you're going on any sort of like
normal length vacation over the summer
you don't need to worry about it like
you you're you're not going to lose
enough muscle or strength
to
to lose sleep over and when you when you
get back to the gym you're gonna get it
all back in a week or two like it's
totally fine don't worry about it
and if you are still worried about it
take five minutes a day do one set of
push-ups one set of pull-ups one
reasonably hard set of split squats and
then go about your day
that that's that's going to maintain
your gains for
you know if
certainly for a two-week vacation
probably for like six months out of the
gym um
yeah that that's like that is the
ultimate security blanket just doing a
little bit of something it doesn't have
to be much just doing a little bit uh
consistently will
help you maintain the muscle and
strength you have very effectively for a
very long period of time